once your launch page is ready to go
you'll have a few options for where to
list your app like the Google Play Store
the iOS App Store or even the Chrome Web
Store you can develop your app to be
compatible with all the different out
stores out there but before you work too
hard you may want to start with focusing
on the best app store for your needs now
think about your audience and what
they're more likely to use read the
market share research to validate your
assumption now if you focus on a
specific region you can easily find out
which operating system dominates that
market and you can develop your app
accordingly our example here will be how
to launch on the Android Play Store
since Android dominates the global
market each store has its own methods
and requirements to launching these
things change over time so the best
thing for you to do is check out their
documentation we've linked to various
stores in the instructor notes in the
long term you don't need to choose one
App Store over another if you have an
app that fits many different platforms
that way you can reach more customers
but focusing on one first can help you
validate and perfect your idea before
expanding to another platform